claude blanchemaison merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors cep
annonce britannique sur les frontières
que signifie tel signifie que le
gouvernement britannique veut montrer
qu'il est paré à toute éventualité le
monde veut montrer à son opinion
publique mais aussi à l'union européenne
et ce quelle que soit l'issue de la
négociation en cours pour un accord de
libre échange avec l'union européenne
que cette négociation aboutisse à un
accord de libre échange ou pas alors de
toute manière le gouvernement
britannique a décidé l'a appelée
beaucoup de fois que la grande bretagne
le royaume uni campagne sortira de
l'union douanière le 31 décembre à
minuit le 31 décembre prochain et on
recrute 500 le douanier et policier des
frontières ce qui est finalement assez
peu c'est assez peu parce que ces
douaniers et ses policiers des
frontières
on va avoir à gérer une situation tout à
fait nouvelle et complexe d'ailleurs
moins complexe très paradoxalement si il
n'y a pas d'accord de libre-échange
parce qu'à ce moment là ils auront
appliqué un tarif douanier britannique
uniforme à toutes importations venant de
l'extérieur vers le royaume uni
si en revanche il y à un accord de libre
échange eh bien ils devront différencié
en fonction de l'origine des produits
et c'est parfois assez compliqué le
différencier l'origine véritable des
produits puisque à ce moment-là il
rentrerait sans droits de douane dans le
dans le royaume uni s'ils viennent de
l'union européenne et avec des droits de
douane du tarif britannique le nouveau
tarif britannique qui sera mis en
vigueur à ce moment là s'ils viennent de
pays tiers
pour le moment on ne peut pas dire on ne
le sait pas et c'est vrai que le
gouvernement britannique tient à montrer
que l'administration britannique est en
ordre de bataille pour cette échéance
qui est dans quatre ou cinq mois très
proche
ça n'est pas si sûr ce n'est pas si sûr
parce que il faut recruter les
techniciens allaient éloigner et il faut
également les former alors qu'elle un
silence à l'intérieur du royaume uni et
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
alors à l'intérieur du royaume uni il ya
évidemment un problème majeur qui est
celui des rennais
puisqu'il se trouve que la république
d'irlande est un état membre de l'union
européenne elle est d'ailleurs entrée
dans l'union européenne en même temps
que le royaume uni en 1973 et il y a un
au nord de l'irlande de l'irlande du
nord ulster qui fait partie du royaume
uni qui est une composante du royaume
uni or à la suite de l'accord de paix
entre le premier ministre britannique
tony blair et le premier ministre
irlandais de l'époque plus les
unionistes et les nationalistes du nord
de l'irlande
on appelle ça l'accord du vendredi saint
de 1998 et bien suite à cet accord
progressivement on a supprimé toute
trace de frontière entre la république
d'irlande et l'irlande du nord qui fait
partie du royaume uni si vous traversez
cette ligne c'est une ligne fictive il
n'y a aucun panneau les gens circulent
librement les marchandises aussi les
animaux aussi puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
fermes dans ce land cette ligne qui fait
500 km alors la grande question est
comment faire pour marquer que le nord
de l'iran qui fait partie du royaume uni
sort lui aussi de l'union douanière le
1er janvier prochain alors que la
république d'irlande restent dans
l'union européenne et dans donc dans
l'union douanière sans rétablir une
frontière et naturellement c'est un
enjeu majeur parce que monsieur boris
johnson s'est bien que s'il rétablit une
frontière physique et bien on ira vers
de nouvelles tensions politiques vers de
nouveaux troubles
et c'est pour ça que dans l'accord
transitoire pour l'année en cours avec
l'union européenne
il est prévu un dispositif assez
complexe de poursuivre suivre les
produits qui se dirigeront vers la
grande île irlandaise avec des procédés
numériques d'une assez grande complexité
et reste à voir si cela marchera du côté
de l'union européenne on a aussi un
intérêt à ce que cela marche parce que
personne n'a intérêt à ce que le conflit
qui a duré 30 ans qui a fait 4000 morts
soit ressuscité entre l'irlande du nord
et la république d'irlande
donc c'est évidemment un enjeu majeur et
l'union européenne avaient démontré par
la sa capacité à développer la paix sur
son territoire puisqu'elle avait
largement contribué à cet accord de paix
du vendredi saint
du côté de l'union européenne donc on
tient beaucoup à qui est pas
rétablissement d'une frontière physique
alors pour conclure cette dernière
question faire de cette frontière la
plus efficace du monde d'ici à 2025 ce
sont les mots du ministre d'état à
michael gove
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quelles
seront les conséquences mathieu
déclaration étrange parce que j'allais
vous dire dans la ligne de ce que je
viens d'expliquer que la frontière doit
être efficace dès le 1er janvier
prochain puisque les britanniques ont
décidé de sortir avec l'irlande du nord
de l'union douanière de l'union
européenne évidemment la frontière doit
être efficace dès le 1er janvier
prochain et pas dans cinq ans et pas
dans cinq ans il y a urgence et en effet
qu'il y est d'ailleurs un accord de
libre échange ou pas entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne l'union
européenne ne pourra pas s'accommoder
d'un régime laxiste
le premier ministre barry johnson a dit
mais nous mettrons les choses en vigueur
progressivement progressivement non il
ya un changement de nature juridique à
partir du 1er janvier prochain et
l'union européenne appliquera les règles
qui sont les siennes à ses frontières
sont toutefois rétablir une frontière
physique au milieu de l'irlande alors
effectivement je donne un exemple par
exemple supposer que de la viande
australiennes ou néo zélandaise puisse
arriver sans droits de douane royaume
uni il est évidemment pas possible pour
l'union européenne d'accepter que ceux
ci étant rentré en ulster en irlande du
nord puisse passer puisqu'il ya pas de
frontières dans république d'irlande et
par conséquent sur le marché unique
donc ça sujet d'une assez grande
complexité mais qui soulèvera de grands
problèmes politiques à l'avenir et je
pense que nous aurons à en discuter avec
les britanniques
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse est votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes est vous êtes
pardon expert en relations
internationales